I think I got friends zone right there,
a viral New York Times article featured 36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people falling in love.
We want it to see what would happen if we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name's Nicole Ross and I am currently single.
I have no idea what to expect from today,
but I'm excited for
the turnout.
My Name is David Simmons.
I'm single,
but you know,
hopefully this is going to help me find like my perfect match.
The worst thing that could happen is
am I allowed to say the complete opposite of like what I am into comes out and
like,
okay.
I'm just hoping like we're not going to even have to have like the worst
possible thing.
Jeez.
What is up?
Hello,
how are you?
Great.
Nicole.
Nice to meet David.
Nice to meet you.
Oh yeah,
we're hugging the second floor.
You're my new wife now.
Know why I just decided right now.
Oh Wow.
That's a big leap right to it were to have like a beach date.
This will read to do or do you like get on those little bird things?
We're just going to be flying down like the little pier.
It's going to be fun.
All right.
Right there.
Right.
You're down.
I've been wanting to ride bikes on the pier,
so we're doing it sounds like a plan.
When did you last sing to yourself and to some,
one
last thing to myself was probably like in my Uber here and you're like,
what am I up for?
Trevor and I were like bumped it.
I think I say to myself every day,
but last time I was saying to someone else last from my best friend's birthday
saying happy birthday.
Bye.
That was like the remix variation.
And you now are you like to,
yeah.
What is the greatest accomplishment of your life?
Well,
I have a lot you finding myself because growing up I never,
I always felt like I was missing something.
I never knew what it was and kind of always like relied on other people to fill
my happiness and feel,
um,
just the void that I always wanted filled.
All it took was finding that love and I'm trusting yourself to be able to do
anything you want in life.
Wow.
That,
that was honestly insane.
Like I'd never heard anything like more well set did that and can you just made
my accomplishments just like feel like shit.
So I would say that my greatest accomplishment,
not,
I wouldn't say fighting myself because I'm not entirely sure if I found myself
yet right.
Entirely.
But it would just be like learning how to get out of like the social norm.
Everyone just feels like you have to live one certain way and like that's the
only way.
Like you can do anything with your life
and just even like moving out here on your own is a huge accomplishment.
Being on your own.
Thanks a lot.
Yeah,
there's so much that you can save for that,
but I think that was good.
Yeah.
What is your most terrible memory?
Terrible memory.
A high school senior night,
you know,
I was like on the basketball team I was like,
all right,
I'm going to ask this.
Go to prom.
It's going to be awesome.
I had like people in like the stands holding like prom,
spelled out walk.
My little brother and I over to this girl asked her to like,
uh,
go to prom with me.
She like looked in front of me and she's like,
no.
I was like,
okay,
I want to know each other.
Yeah.
Like we talked for a super long time,
but I like she said no by of everyone's.
I was like,
okay,
cool.
She liked,
obviously felt bad,
but it is kind of comical.
So like I look back and laugh.
Wow,
that's horrible.
Never forget your sure.
Bad Karma came her way.
Um,
my most terrible memory would probably be like right before I moved out here to
California.
I got in this wreck and I had never been in a wreck before and this guy was
drunk driving and it was like late at night and he completely t-boned.
He had this huge truck and just drove right into me and I just really thought I
was like about to die that night and I was just like freaking out and I will
never forget.
I just like did not know how to react to the rec and I was like crying and try
and get out of the car but I didn't know how to get out of the car cause I was
in so much shock and and so yeah it was just like a terrible feeling.
I never want to experience again and it just really made me mad that he was like
drunk and
that is crazy.
But I at least I lived.
Yeah definitely cause like you lived and you still look fine as fuck.
Like awesome.
Yeah.
What do you value most in a friendship?
Me and just be being trustworthy.
We make friends easily.
I can imagine like you seem really social but like you probably went past people
that I like ended up kind of like screwing you over,
something like that when he never thought they would.
I'm 110% honest with all my friends.
I'm going to be like,
hopefully you do that in return and like not try to like just use me to like
benefit yourself,
but like maybe just like we'd benefit each other like I don't know,
like everything takes a team.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think mine would definitely be loyalty but also guidance.
Like I love having friends that like are constantly making sure I'm doing what
my heart is calling me to do.
You know?
Like if you're trying to distract me and I'm like steering me away from
bettering myself,
then I feel like that's not really a good friendship.
I'm going to need to keep you around just because like you're in a set me
straight.
That's my job.
Okay.
When did you last cry?
In front of another person and by herself?
Oh,
well I just recently broke up with my ex,
so like all my friends had to deal with me like crying and like being soft.
I don't want to give like my time and effort to someone just to get shattered.
It's how you learn,
I guess.
Can I go through heartbreak?
If not,
you never know.
That's the last time you cried.
Oh yeah.
Ooh,
that's pretty good.
I feel like I cry a lot.
Um,
the last time I cried in front of another person was probably like at church,
you know,
they always say some emotional staffs and then you're like,
you need a Napkin.
I'm like,
so they saw me crying.
Ooh,
I like this one.
So,
uh,
would you go on a second date with your partner?
Aka me?
I'm sorry.
I didn't really like see like the common is like in that,
yeah,
you're like,
ah,
yeah,
well I'm the kind of person where like,
I don't really like to consider a date.
Like I like to really get to know someone.
So if we're hanging out as friends then yes,
because I mean that's like you're still spending time,
but I feel like if it's like a date,
then you have to look at it like,
okay,
I'm going to be in a relationship with this person.
So I'm Kinda like old school with it.
I go with the flow.
If it's meant to happen again,
then will definitely happen again.
If not,
then we definitely got the experience from it,
you know?
Okay,
well that's Loki hurt my feelings,
but
I did not say we're not ever going to see each other again.
No.
Because I already know are going to.
Exactly.
So shouldn't be hurt I suppose.
But uh,
yes,
I would definitely go on another date with you and,
uh,
I guess when we leave here,
that's when it starts.
Yeah.
So we're taking another sip of tea on that one.
All right.
Cheers.
Of course.
New Friendships.
I think I got friends,
right?
Ashley?
I new friendships.
I clicked off that you're going to get to date me clearly.
I'm just checking my heart tech.
I'm a pro fisherman,
so I guess I'll find out just like real.
And if you said
it'd be fun,
I folks,
I'm Dan and I'm Jason,
thank you so much for watching another episode of tea for two.
We love this series and we hope you do too.
That's right.
Um,
as always,
make sure that you subscribe and like,
you know what,
from videos and we will see you guys next time.
Spread love.